[MUSIC PLAYING]
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- I'll tell people,
I work at Google.
And they go, what
do you work on?
I design Search.
And they kind of
pause for a second
and they're like, what
is there to design?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Oh, I know.
It's cat.
[BEEP]
- Hi.
How can I help?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
BRENDA FOGG: Hello, everybody.
I'm Brenda Fogg.
I work in the
Creative Lab, which
is sort of a multi-disciplinary
creative group within Google
that often collaborates
with other teams
across the company on product
or technology experiments.
And sometimes, finding new
ways to talk about some
of the innovative work that's
going on inside of Google.
And at some point
over the years,
I've worked with
each of our panelists
on some of those projects that
you probably saw on the video
just now.
So we're going to talk a
little bit about some things
that you may have seen.
A little bit about
design at Google
and what that means as sort
of a fundamental framework
and connective tissue between
the things that Google makes
and making them as useful and
accessible to as many people as
possible.
So let's start with
some introductions.
We have Doug Eck
right here to my left,
who leads a project
called Magenta,
which is all about
exploring machine learning
and creativity.
We have Isabelle Olsson, who's
responsible for the design
of the Google Home and
wearables and hardware.
And over there is Ryan
Germick, Principal Designer,
who also is known
as the Doodle guy.
And has been quite involved
in the Google Assistant.
And generally, just
in the business
of delighting users everywhere.
So let's start by
letting everybody
talk a little bit about
what you do at Google.
And we'll start with
Doug, because you're
sitting next to me.
You head up this
project called Magenta.
For anybody who doesn't
know exactly what that is,
maybe you can talk a
little bit about that.
And maybe touch on
what inspired the group
and the focus of the team.
DOUGLAS ECK: OK, sure.
So yeah, I lead a
project called Magenta.
The M-A-G in Magenta stands
for Music and Art Generation.
And we started by trying
to understand the capacity
to use AI, specifically
machine learning,
to generate music and art.
And it took us about a
month to realize that that's
asking the wrong question.
Because if all you're
doing is trying
to generate music
and art, then you
just keep pushing this button
and the machine learning
keeps making music
and art for you.
And it gets boring fast.
So we pivoted very
quickly to talking about,
how can we use machine learning
to enable artists and enable
musicians to make something new?
To make something different?
So it's sitting on the same
idea of technology and art
interacting with one
another in a virtuous way,
starting with cave
drawings and moving forward
through the film camera and
other bits of technology.
So yeah, I'm about
AI and art and music.
BRENDA FOGG: So
you're not necessarily
trying to replace creativity
or duplicate creativity,
but more providing the tools
to enable people to do that?
DOUGLAS ECK: Yeah.
And I think it's not
just because that's
what we choose to focus on.
I think creativity is
fundamentally human.
And it's about communication.
So if we take the
communication loop out,
we can imagine in some
analytical way, a computer
generating new things.
But what makes creativity
work is how we respond to it
and how we then feedback
in to that process.
So I think it's very much a
societal communicative act.
BRENDA FOGG: And that idea
of creating new things,
like maybe some
things that weren't
necessarily possible before.
That weren't humanly
possible to create.
So there's an-- I don't know
if you want to talk about this,
but this example that was shown
in the lead-up into the keynote
yesterday.
The NSynth Project, which
is one of those things
that can sort of augment
what human creativity can do.
You want to touch on that?
DOUGLAS ECK: Yeah, sure.
For NSynth and the
following hardware device,
NSynth Super, you
may have seen was
played on stage before the
keynote and discussed there.
I think the main
idea there is, can we
use machine learning to allow
us to generate new sounds?
And sounds that are
musically meaningful to us?
And one thing to point
out is that we already
have ways to do that.
There's a bunch
of great software.
I have a piano at my house,
so I can-- and a guitar.
There are lots of
ways to make sounds.
What we hope we can
get is some kind
of expressive edge with AI.
Something that we can
do with these models.
A kind of intuitiveness
or a kind of new kind
of mobility artistically
by having a new tool.
And the one thing I
would say, I don't
want to take up too much
time because there's
a lot of other great
people here on stage.
But I really like to think
about the film camera.
The film camera
was initially not
treated as an artistic device.
It was treated as something
to capture reality.
And it was transformed
into an artistic device
by artists, by photographers.
And our hope on
Magenta is that we
find the right artists
and the right musicians
to take what we're
doing and turn it
into something creative.
BRENDA FOGG: So
turning something
into creative, Isabelle.
When you're designing a
product, the Home for example,
you're trying to create
something that appeals
to everyone through its design.
But everybody's
different, right?
So these are physical products
that share a physical space
with the people that use them.
And like sometimes,
you have to cohabitate.
So talk a little bit about
how you approach that problem.
ISABELLE OLSSON: Yeah.
I mean, I think I have
the utmost respect
for people's homes.
And like you said,
they're all different.
And I think next to
your body, your home
is your most intimate space.
And it's the place for
you share with your loved
ones and your family.
So to enter that space
with our products,
we have to be super-thoughtful
about what we do there.
And I think for us, the
most important thing
is to be inspired by the context
in which our products live in.
So when we were designing
Google Home Mini for example,
the goal was to design an
Assistant for every room.
And that means
your bedside table.
And your bedside table,
that's where you put devices
that help you see better.
Or like, a book that
helps you dream.
So that space is
just so special.
We wanted to create
something that was beautiful,
that fit into the home,
and didn't take up
too much attention, and
kind of faded a little bit
into the background.
BRENDA FOGG: And you're
also responsible for CMF
at Google, which is Color
Material Finish, right?
ISABELLE OLSSON: Yes.
BRENDA FOGG: And I've heard
this story about testing,
like 150 different versions of
color palettes for the Mini.
Is that right?
ISABELLE OLSSON: Yeah.
I mean, I think for us,
developing the color palette
for the Google
family of products
and individual
products is a very--
it's a combination of art
and science, I would say.
And we start usually
two to three years
before the products come out.
So we have to do a
lot of anticipation
of where society is going,
where trends are going.
And take all of
those kind of inputs
into account to make sure that
when we release a product,
it makes sense to people.
In addition to that, of course
when you design for the home,
you have to think about the fact
that there is going to be light
hitting the product.
How does it stand
the test of time?
We want to make sure the
products look beautiful
for a long time.
So we have to go through a lot
of iteration to get it right.
And then also,
especially as we're
developing fabrics for example,
depending on where you put it,
it takes different--
it looks different in
different lighting conditions.
So when we designed
Mini, we went through,
I think 150 iterations
of just the gray color.
But it was a lot of fun.
And it was about finding
that right balance with,
what is too light?
What's too dark?
And the other day, I got
this lovely email by someone
on the team who had picked out
his couch to match Google Home
Max.
So I took that as
a giant compliment
because we were trying to
do it the other way around.
But that was a beautiful story.
BRENDA FOGG: What is the
intersection of the intuition
that you use as a
designer when you approach
these kinds of problems with
the sort of iterative testing?
And sort of the scientific
materials examination?
ISABELLE OLSSON: Yeah,
it's a hodgepodge.
The process is not linear.
It's pretty messy, usually.
But we have fun with it.
I think the key is gather
as much input as possible,
and then digest it.
And then, come up with
prototypes and ways
of relating to how this will
fit into people's homes.
So even right next to my
desk, I have a big bookshelf
that we place random
objects from all
over the world for inspiration.
But also, to kind of put
our stuff there quickly
to see, how does it feel?
And how does it feel over time?
Because it's not only
about creating something
that you are first
attracted to, but it
has to be things that you can
live with for a long time.
BRENDA FOGG: So Ryan, you
lead the Google Doodles team.
And this team is unique
in a lot of ways.
Namely, one of them is that you
regularly and willfully break
the brand rules.
RYAN GERMICK: Gleefully, yeah.
BRENDA FOGG:
Gleefully for Google.
In fact, on a daily
basis, many, many times.
And that's unusual because
it's the core of the brand.
And that's something that seems
to keep working and working
and working over the years.
So talk a little
bit about why you
think it's important to
have the ability to kind
of just mess with it.
RYAN GERMICK: Sure.
I mean, Google's mission
is to organize the world's
information and
make it universally
accessible and useful.
And I believe in that mission.
I think it's a very powerful,
good thing to do for the world.
And we hone in on
the idea of making
things accessible by creating
an emotional connection
with users.
And sometimes, like
mucking up the standards.
That's like collateral
damage for people
getting a positive charge
and learning something new
or having fun with something,
then we think it's worthwhile.
And yeah, I think
on a human level,
there are things that are more
important than consistency.
It's, for us, more about
using our creativity and craft
to make people feel welcome
in the space of technology.
BRENDA FOGG: Yeah.
So making people feel welcome
in the space of technology.
You also lead the team who
created the personality
for the Google Assistant.
RYAN GERMICK: Right.
BRENDA FOGG: And how do
you create a personality?
I mean, there's sort of the
transactional things that
have to happen between a
user when they're interacting
with a digital assistant.
And they have an
expectation that they're
going to be delivered
the information that they
asked for.
And you felt like it needed
to go a little bit farther
than that sort of
transactional relationship.
But people have-- a
little bit the way
we were talking with
Isabella, everyone
has different things that
they like to interact with.
And some people like small
talk and some people don't.
And some people think things are
funny that other people think
are totally not funny at all.
Talk a little about that.
RYAN GERMICK: Yeah.
I mean, I think that
as Isabella mentioned,
that technology, like
the assistant that
comes in a smart speaker,
or a smart display,
or in your phone,
is really personal.
That's one thing.
And so we recognize that we
have a different set of design
challenges than if it was more
objective, like a Google Search
engine [INAUDIBLE].
And then also, when you
invite this technology
into your life--
we're using this conversational
interface as a metaphor.
You can talk to it and
it can respond to you.
And as soon as you
hear the human voice,
it not only opens
up an opportunity
to have a character,
but what we've seen,
it's almost like an obligation
to design for the character.
Because if you
don't design for it,
then people will just assume you
don't have much of a character.
But there's still some
implicit character.
So we took the learnings
that we had from Doodles,
and being an implicit
character for Google
where we celebrate
certain things
and we get creative
and nerdy and excited.
And we tried to transfer that
over to the Google Assistant,
where it could be
like a character
that you'd want to spend time
with because it has things
that it gets excited about.
Or it has a perspective where
it really wants to help you.
And not just be something
that you want to use,
but something that you
want to spend time with.
So yeah, surprising
number of the principles
are things that
we did for Doodles
were applicable for
the Google Assistant.
And it's a huge project.
And there's a lot of
pieces to the puzzle,
but we think it's an important
part of the user experience
to have a sense of
who the character is.
BRENDA FOGG: Yeah.
So each of you have
talked a little bit
about how technology interacts
with humans and vice-versa.
And how those two things
have to kind of co-exist.
So good design and
thoughtful design
is a means to make
technology, in this case,
more approachable and
useful and usable.
And friendly.
And to make people
comfortable with that.
And you all approach your
work and problem-solving
in this way from a very
human perspective, right?
A very like-- you
inject empathy.
We're going to get real and
talk about humanity and empathy,
right?
Injecting this empathy
into your process.
So let's talk about that.
Doug, do you think--
can the work you do with
machine learning allow a machine
to express art in a human way?
Let's start there.
DOUGLAS ECK: Start there.
Yes, with some constraints
on how this all works.
I think what we
realized early was
that we need at least
two players in this game,
so to speak.
Part of the work is
building new technology.
So in some sense, we're
taking on the role
that a luthier might take
on in building a guitar.
Or that someone doing
a music tech program
might take on in building a new
kind of electronic instrument.
And I think there's a
thought process that
goes with building
something like that
that is very creative.
But I think you're also in
some very real way constrained
by the act of
building the thing.
To understand it
in a certain way.
It's your baby.
You built it.
And so you know-- you
wrote the operating manual,
so you know what this
thing is supposed to do.
And in most cases, what we see
is that for something to become
a truly expressive,
artistic device,
it has to in some very real
way be broken by someone else.
And I think it's almost
impossible for us
as the builders of
that device to also
be the ones that break it.
And so our dream in Magenta
is to connect with artists
and musicians and people.
People that don't
know how to code.
necessarily even care
much about computation and draw
them into this conversation.
And so what we found is that
we started by releasing machine
learning models in open source
on GitHub as part of TensorFlow
with instructions like, please
run this 15-line-long Python
command.
It's going to be great.
Just run this command
and hit Enter.
And then, just
wait because you're
going to get 100 MIDI files
in a temp directory somewhere
on your machine, right?
Everybody's like, that's
not how I make music.
So what we've seen is
that part of our work,
even on the technologist side,
even as luthiers, so to speak--
guitar makers--
part of our job is
to do good design.
And to build interfaces
that people can use.
And then, hopefully
the interfaces
are flexible enough
and expressive enough
that in some very
meaningful way,
people can also do
some fun breakage.
And getting there requires
a lot of moving parts.
A large component of
which is very good design.
BRENDA FOGG: I like that
notion of breaking things.
You told a story once about--
or you made an analogy once
about the electric guitar,
I think, and how that's
a little bit similar.
Like the dissonance
that people create
with electric guitars is not--
DOUGLAS ECK: Yeah.
That's right.
So first, I tell
the same stories.
I'm like the grandpa--
BRENDA FOGG: Well, I don't know
if you tell it to everybody.
DOUGLAS ECK: Please,
tell us that story again.
No, but it's true.
The electric guitar was invented
to be a loud acoustic guitar.
To overcome noise on stage.
And the worst-- they were
trying really hard to not
have these amplifiers distort.
So imagine a world where
amplifiers don't distort
and electric guitars sound
like acoustic guitars.
You actually haven't
moved very far.
And the breakage
there was actually
having fun with the distortion.
And actually, going
for sounds that aren't
like an acoustic guitar.
BRENDA FOGG: Let's
go back to Isabelle.
One of the things I think that's
so interesting about your work,
and that people
have to co-habitate
with these physical
things, is that it's just
as important, or
maybe more important,
how people feel
about these things
rather than just what
their utility is.
What kind of considerations
do you make for--
we're starting to
sound like hippies now.
But like, what people's feelings
and their empathies and the way
they co-exist in the
space with these things?
ISABELLE OLSSON: I
think a good tool
that I use a lot is that I
put stuff in front of people
and ask them, what do
you think it looks like?
It's a fun game.
You don't always get back
what you want to hear.
But it's a really
good way of testing
if the object you've
created, does it
have positive connotations
or negative connotations?
The first time I showed
a prototype of Mini,
I showed it to a French person
who said, it's like a macaron.
And I thought that was
amazing because, first of all,
I love macarons.
And then, I think having
something connotate
something sweet and
delicious is just excellent.
And again, we surround
ourselves with food.
That was just--
I knew we were onto
something there.
And food is something
universally appealing,
generally.
So that's one
exercise out of many.
I think the key is just
to really make the thing
real really quickly.
To translate the big
idea into something
tangible, and then ourselves
living with it for a while,
too.
And then also,
think about not only
the food analogies,
but also making sure
that the objects we
design are understandable.
You understand what it is.
So again with Mini,
we wanted it to look
a little bit like a speaker and
a little bit like a microphone,
but not too much of either.
But be very honest
to that function.
And then, connotate that
this goes in the home.
And therefore, the fabrics
and the things that we use to
surround ourselves with.
BRENDA FOGG: Yeah.
It has to have that
human touch to it
as part of the design process.
ISABELLE OLSSON:
And the beauty of it
is when you find these
solutions, a lot of the times,
they enhance the function
or help with the function.
Like fabric is this
excellent material
that is most of the
time audio transparent.
You can have lights through it.
You can kind of create this
calmness in the object itself
by getting all the
functionality through it.
And I'm really
passionate about trying
to design pieces of technology,
which hopefully people think
about they're just stuff
and not as technology,
but that can live
out in the open.
There's just way too
many pieces of furniture
that are purely designed
to hide technology.
So my goal in life is if we
could get rid of those things.
BRENDA FOGG: And Ryan,
that sort of human touch
is pretty evident in most
everything that you do.
So if we can talk about
the Google Assistant again.
It was designed to
operate and to be
used through the
power of conversation,
which is a fundamental
human interface, I guess.
And through the course of your
work on creating a personality,
talk a little bit about how
you sort of steered through
the landmines of
what kinds of-- aside
from the transactional
things, what kinds of things
are people going to want to
talk about with their Assistant?
RYAN GERMICK: Yeah.
I mean, I think this
may be a bit cliche,
but it's so early days.
So I think we're still steering.
But for us, a guiding
principle for our success
is, is a feeling thing.
Does this feel like a character
you want to spend time with,
like I mentioned earlier.
As far as like finding
things that people--
we wanted to steer clear of.
I mean, it was really
interesting to look
at the different queries that
people ask Google Search,
and then what people
ask Google Assistant.
And at Google, as
you might imagine,
there's a lot of people
that have a background
in like information retrieval.
And like, data ranking,
things like search ranking,
things like that.
And it kind of turned
things on their head
when now people are
asking questions like,
what's your favorite
flavor of ice cream?
Or like, did you fart?
And those are like pretty--
more common than you
think when people first
get a piece of technology
that's been lovingly crafted.
They all of a sudden have a very
different relationship to it.
A very sizable
number of the queries
that we get on the
Google Assistant
are like, first-date queries.
Like, do you have any
brothers or sisters?
It's really sweet.
DOUGLAS ECK: Ryan, you're
the only person that can--
what is her favorite
flavor of ice cream?
I'm sure everybody
wants to know.
RYAN GERMICK: This is a very
illuminating question, Doug.
Thank you for asking.
So basically, we
have a principle.
And this speaks to
Brenda's question, too.
We basically set up
principles where we--
for example, we
have one principle
that we want to
talk like a human.
We want to take advantage of the
human voice and the interface.
But we don't want to
pretend to be one.
So if you were to
ask a question like,
what's your favorite
flavor of ice cream,
we would do what we would
call an artful dodge.
And we look to our
training in improv theater
where we don't want to
deny the user of like,
I do not eat ice cream.
I do not have a mouth.
That's like a really
bummer answer.
If you're exploring
a new technology,
that's a shut down
to the conversation.
But at the same
time, we don't want
to lie and say like, well,
salted caramel, obviously.
This is like a position that
is disingenuous because it
does not eat ice cream.
So we would say
something like, you
can't go wrong with Neapolitan.
There's something
in it for everyone.
And we would take that
question, understand
that the subtext is like, I'm
getting to know what you are
and what your capabilities are.
And we would-- yes, and.
And we would kind of
continue to play the game.
And use it actually
as an opportunity
to make a value statement
that we're inclusive.
And we want everybody to know--
we want to reflect that ice
cream that is good for everyone
is good.
BRENDA FOGG: How much dialog
goes on within your team
when you're trying to--
when you're talking about, OK.
What if someone asks the
Google Assistant, do you fart?
RYAN GERMICK: Yeah.
As soon as that question I
knew was going to be answered.
And it wasn't just going
to default to an answer,
I knew that we already won.
The humanist amongst
us already won.
Because there was a school of
thought that you would say,
I don't fart.
I don't have a body.
And that was like, end of story.
And that just seems--
that's true, but
kind of not in line
with keeping the game going.
So we would have a
lot of back and forth.
And we would then
like, take that answer.
And we'd say, well, at least you
could say, I don't have a butt.
Because at least then you'd
be a little more specific.
BRENDA FOGG: Start there.
No butt.
RYAN GERMICK: But
in our case, we
ended up with something a little
more playful and little more
addressing the subtext, which is
of the school of like, whoever
smelt it, dealt it.
Which we said, you can
blame me if you want.
I don't mind.
If the user's asking
about that, let's
just take it one step further
and put them on the spot.
BRENDA FOGG: Are
you all going to go
ask your Google Assistant now?
RYAN GERMICK: I think there's
like 25 different answers
because that is definitely
a key use case for--
BRENDA FOGG: Keep asking.
Just keep asking.
OK.
So let's talk a little bit
about how all of this humanity
plays out in the context
of a brand, like Google.
So Isabelle, the Home
Mini, you mentioned,
needed to be both a
speaker and a microphone
as well as an assistant and
behave like an assistant.
So if you're starting from
those kind of very engineering
kind of product
requirements, how
do you go from there into the
idea of personality of a brand?
In Ryan's case, his work talks.
The personality comes
through that way.
In your work, it comes
through sort of the materials
and the things.
How do you consider the
personality of the Google brand
in the work that you do?
ISABELLE OLSSON: Yeah.
I mean, I think it's
a huge responsibility.
And we're only a few
years into making hardware
that people actually
put down money for.
And you know, the brand
is just really incredible.
So we're trying to figure
out, what's core to Google?
And how do we translate
that into physical form?
And sometimes, it's not
about a direct translation.
Because most people
don't want to pay money
for something quirky, maybe.
So taking that kind of
principle and that idea,
and then thinking about
what it means for hardware.
So in this case
for example, to me,
Google stands for a
sense of optimism.
And kind of this optimistic
outlook on the future.
So if I can do things that
remind people of that or that
makes people smile, I think
that that naturally then feels
like a Google product.
So just one simple
example of that
is you turn Mini
upside down, there
is a pop of color on the back.
And only you as a person who
bought the product know that.
But you know it kind of has
that Google on the inside.
BRENDA FOGG: Yeah.
Let's go back to Ryan then.
Because over the years,
over seven or eight years,
or whatever.
However many years you've been--
DOUGLAS ECK: 12 almost.
BRENDA FOGG: 12 years.
You've had a lot
of opportunities
to craft those sort
of moments of delight
and those sort of
little user experiences
that are like
turning over the Mini
and finding a little surprise.
So everything from-- you're
responsible for the Pegman,
which is the character that
you drop into Google Maps
when you go into Street View.
And we talked about the
personality of the Google
Assistant a little bit.
And then of course, the Doodles
taking over the Home page.
So over the 12 years
that you've been
kind of working
in that territory,
and as the Google brand
has grown and evolved,
have you found-- how has that
growth of the brand impacted
the work that you do?
RYAN GERMICK: I think the
core of what I try to do,
I almost discovered
it by accident.
Like the Street
View Pegman, maybe
is a story for another day.
But I was just
glad that I worked
in a place that had free
strawberries when I got here.
That was very exciting to me.
And then, that they paid
me to draw and be creative
was just beyond
my wildest dream.
So I'm just like,
happy to be here.
Still, I'm happy to be here.
But what kind of worked for
me because it was always
sort of my MO was, how can I
use my position of privilege
to bring other people up and to
give them a sense of belonging?
And that has stayed consistent.
So whether it's trying to make
sure we have inclusive Doodles
or creating an opportunity for
a little, like mannequin that
can be dressed up for holidays
or whatever, for Street View.
There's been a through line
where maybe in the beginning,
Google was more of an underdog.
And now, Google is like
a very important part
of people's lives.
I don't think you could really
say it's a small organization,
by any stretch.
But there are still
human touch points
that matter to make people
feel like they belong,
which is what Google's
trying to do for everyone.
BRENDA FOGG: I want to make sure
we leave time for questions,
if anybody has them.
So if you have
questions, you could
start coming to the
microphones while we kind of go
a little bit into the future.
Let's talk about the future.
So if we're sitting here a
year from now or a few years
from now, Doug, what do you
expect that machine learning
might do for art in the future?
Whether it's your aspirations
for the next 12 or 18 months,
or maybe 5 years from now.
DOUGLAS ECK: So I think
the really interesting way
to think about this is consider
generative models as a family
of machine learning models.
Models that generate new
instances of the data
upon which they're trained.
Where I see us going is actually
very heavily integrating
the design process of products
with generative models.
We're seeing machine
learning generating part
of what we're trying to do.
And I think that's going to
touch our lives in the arts
and music and communication
in a number of ways.
And to those of you
who are-- anybody
in the room a developer?
It's an easy question
because we're at a developer
conference, right?
So we're going to
have a responsibility
as machine learning
experts to understand
a little bit about design.
A responsibility as
back-end engineers
to understand a little bit about
machine learning and design.
I think we're going to
see much more of a need
for end-to-end integration.
For me, the future started
happening already in a sense.
I have teenage kids, and
I watched just how they
use Snapchat to communicate.
And how they've built their
own kind of grammar around it.
And it's a very,
very simple product.
Now, imagine 10 years of
advances in assistive writing.
So you know, you're using
Google Docs and you're writing.
And you have some machine
learning algorithm
helping you communicate, right?
We're going to get very
good at this very fast.
And I expect that when
my kids were younger,
the teachers were all worried
if they used Wikipedia
too much to write their papers.
And now it's going to be
like, wait, how much of this
did you actually write?
What part of it did you write?
And what part of it did
your Assistant write?
And I think we can be
dystopian about that.
There are potentially some
very difficult issues here.
But it's also
wonderful, I think.
As long as we use
this to communicate
more effectively and
in different ways,
and we make it into
something creative,
I think it's very
exciting to think
about how machine
learning can become
really more deeply integrated
in the process of communicating.
And again, that's what I
see the arts as being about
and music being about.
It's about communicating.
It's about sharing our
thoughts, our feelings,
our beliefs with each other.
And I'm seeing in my career
that happening more deeply
with machine learning as well.
So that's my future vision.
BRENDA FOGG: I love it.
I love your vision.
Isabelle, what about hardware?
What do you what do you
want to see in hardware
in the next year or two?
ISABELLE OLSSON:
Well, number 1, I
hope people find out about it.
So we just did a small
exhibition in Milan
a couple of weeks ago.
And part of the exhibition
was the portfolio
that we launched last year.
A lot of people will
come up to me and say,
these concepts are great.
And I'm like,
they're not concepts.
They're actual products.
So I think it was a
little bit of that.
And then, I hope we
just continue to design
for everyone in everyday life.
BRENDA FOGG: And Ryan,
what would you like to--
what would you say?
What would you like
people to take away today?
RYAN GERMICK: I think just
remember that technology is
for people, first and foremost.
So just always
keep that question
in the back of
your mind of like,
how is what I'm
doing helping people?
BRENDA FOGG: OK.
Do we have questions?
[MUSIC PLAYING]